bonjour je me présente
ian hamel je suis plus d'un directeur
général des croisières un email une
entreprise a fondé par mon père édouard
1960 et 12
j'ai fait ensuite la question une
entreprise qui appartenait à mon père et
mon oncle en 2006 et là j'ai mangé le
faire de l'x et jouer avec moi depuis
depuis cet automne le passion de la
navigation de la passion du lot une
veille qui tracent prise par mon grand
paris
en fait le père de mon père il était un
cultivateur et il demeurait à cap-rouge
et son hobby été la construction de
bateaux de plaisance mais des bateaux
très particulier en fait détriment de la
première fois au canada quelques
construisait à un trimaran tri mar est
un voilier à trois coques qu'un film une
coque principal et deux flotteurs à
l'extérieur alors fait des années 60 il
construit son premier voilier qui
naviguent sur le saint laurent nous
comme un convoi en fait le scénario
c'est comme la colonne vertébrale du
québec en fait toutes les régions
importantes se griffent hoarau saint
laurent en fait cette passion-là que la
famille développer à naviguer sur tout
le saint laurent
on a voulu la transmettre en fait la
population
mon père a eu l'idée de trouver une
façon simple de
2faire l'appellation de l'entreprise
alors à aimer c'est pour ne pas dire à
1000 tout simplement
alors c'est une façon de faire le lien
avec la famille pour moi la famille
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus important
c'est notre richesse
cécile présent c'est l'avenir autant au
niveau personnel que la société parce
que la famille ben c'est le fil
conducteur à ce que dans notre famille
et lui qui reste jour là alors pour moi
la famille c'est ça une importance
majeure dans toute ma vie